discusses the atheist Madalyn Murray
O'Hair it's a biography of the woman who
founded the American Atheists this talk
runs about an hour
welcome to the c-span crew nice to have
you with us and welcome to all of you
pleased you could join us and that you
have some interest in this really
fascinating woman to whom I hope I can
do some justice tonight what a wonderful
setting to be a unity temple devoted to
all faiths multi-denominational to be
talking about a woman who offended all
faiths so there's some irony in that but
it's a wonderful setting as well in the
rather short time I have to cover this
woman's rather fascinating life I
thought I would focus in essentially on
five questions the first is really about
me that will be brief and the other for
perhaps a little longer first of all how
did I come to write this book Bob
Madalyn Murray O'Hair secondly who was
she because most people know the name
but they get a little confused as to
what exactly she did why did she do what
she did which became very important to
me in my research what was life like for
Madalyn Murray O'Hair after her most
shining moment on in 1963 and then how
did she die
a fate that is still somewhat unclear in
the minds of many people so let's begin
with that and start first of all by
answering how I came to write this book
I'm an historian of American culture and
my various books have dealt with art and
literature public memory and religion on
which I've written quite a bit my
interest in religion is really less
about belief and doctrine and church
teachings than it really is on religion
as a phenomenon in American society I
always found it fascinating to study a
society that takes such great pride on
its provisions in the First Amendment
for
operation of church and state and that
rejects the accuracy of all forms at
home and abroad but by most measures
percentages of people who believe in God
who belong to particular churches who
attend church regularly who believe that
God plays a major role in their lives is
one of the most religious nations on
earth indeed I think we could make the
case perhaps on another night that
really belief in God and in the special
relationship between God and the United
States really a civil religion has been
part of the American psyche or identity
from its very founding and I think you
can see it reflections of it in
presidential rhetoric and phrases such
as one nation under God and our Pledge
of Allegiance our national motto and god
we trust' and so much more what
attracted me to Madalyn Murray O'Hair in
particular was my interest in the place
of atheism non-belief unbelief in such a
nation in a particular the role of
atheism in the United States at a time
period where religion was actually at
its peak when fervor was most intense
during the early Cold War the period of
late 40s 1950s in early 1960s when not
only were more Americans engaged in
espouse and in believing in organized
religion than any other period but also
when our mortal enemy abroad at at home
was atheistic communism and we defined
ourselves largely in terms as being
quite the opposite
free and religious so that led me to
study
Madalyn Murray O'Hair is kind of the
example the epitome of atheism in this
particular time period so who is Madalyn
Murray O'Hair on December 8th 1969
Murray not yet O'Hair filed suit in the
Superior Court of Baltimore Maryland
asking the court to rule required Bible
reading and recitation of the Lord's
Prayer in the city's public schools
unconstitutional she claimed that her
son William's First Amendment rights
were being violated that he was being
discriminated against because he when he
refused to participate
schools morning religious exercise he
was alienated or isolated from his
fellow students defeated in the lower
courts Madeleine appeared what became
Marie V cruel it to the United States
Supreme Court where it was joined with a
similar case out of Pennsylvania Shemp
versus school district of Abington
Township and on June 17th 1963 the court
found in favor of the Murrays and the
shemp's by a margin of 8 to 1 declared
that the Maryland and Pennsylvania laws
violated the Establishment Clause of the
First Amendment effectively removing
organized teacher led prayer from the
public schools although this didn't
occur in a vacuum indeed there were
several cases that led up to this one
the year before in called vitally in
1962 nevertheless much of the nation was
really quite stunned in angry but
whereas the shemp's who had taken a low
profile throughout the case tion Besant
the limelight murray seized it
she took credit for having
single-handedly banned bible reading and
prayer from the nation's public schools
she overstated the case but Americans
searching for someone to blame were only
too willing to accept her claim when she
chose to become the leading proponent of
atheism or opponent of religion
whichever you prefer
she became not only the most visible of
american atheists but she also became as
the press quickly branded her the most
hated woman in America the details of
Madeleine Murray's life who upon her
second marriage in 1968 became Madalyn
Murray O'Hair are fascinating but
equally interesting I think is how
Americans responded to her similarly her
ideas on religion are interesting but no
more so than how those ideas related to
American culture from the Cold War to
the end of the century
as her son William who later broke with
her over her atheist activities wrote
and I think he was at least partly
correct in reality my mother did not
create the time the time created her
Madalyn Murray O'Hair struggled against
the cultural and political consent
on many subjects especially religion not
being content to personally and quietly
reject the idea of belief in God she
launched a crusade against it now
important point here I think we need to
make if you have any memory of Madalyn
Murray O'Hair is in contrast to how the
press and I think her enemies portrayed
her Madalyn Murray O'Hair was really
quite intelligent and well-educated both
formally and informally especially for
the time in which she grew up yes she
was crude
she was vulgar her use of foul language
shocked people but her message was
always accessible to even those with
just a minimal education and she made
very effective use of the media by her
personal behavior somewhat exaggerated
by the enemies her enemies and the press
she personified really what people
expected of atheists she fulfilled
Americans expectations of what would
happen if someone were to lose his or
her faith in God in her hands atheism
was no longer exclusively a matter of
scholarly debate or hushed acceptance
among fringe groups all hair placed it
near the top of America's public agenda
where her enemies maintained it
threatened to subvert debase and pervert
all it was holy or good in American life
now again to understand this we have to
put it in the context in which she was
popular coming of the Cold War witnessed
the campaign against international
communism the fact that the Soviet Union
was not just a military foe but a nation
committed to communism and atheism posed
a unique challenge to the United States
American anti-communist insisted that
communism was not only opposed to
religion but also the natural enemy of
religion in those countries founded on
belief in God
thus communism popularly branded
atheistic communism became anti-american
as well and the United States became a
bulwark against it at home and abroad
this added to the urgency of the battle
against atheism as one observer pointed
out whenever they're up
opponents begin railing against those
atheists the latter cease to be
individuals who mattered to God instead
they became quote a monolithic mass of
faceless enemies and in a war there's no
fraternizing with the other side the
hunt for atheistic communist was on and
to underscore it in 1954 Congress added
the phrase under God to the Pledge of
Allegiance signing the law on Flag Day
June 14th 1954 President Dwight
Eisenhower praised the edition for
reaffirming the transcendence of
religious faith in American heritage and
future on July 11th 1955 he signed a
federal law which required in god we
trust' on the nation's currency on July
30th 1956 he made at the national motto
on July 4th 1953 Eisenhower and Vice
President Nixon launched the march of
freedom a movement intended to affirm
America's spiritual heritage in the
divine basis of its freedom in 1955
Eisenhower told the nation recognition
of the Supreme Being is the first the
most basic expression of Americanism
without God there could be no American
form of government nor any American Way
of life and this continued through the
50s and into the early 60s ohhere Proust
protested that she wasn't a communist at
one point in her life she actually did
grow fairly close to the movement
subscribed to elements and communist
ideology but ultimately she renounced
her ties to communism but even if she
had no involvement with the movement she
would have she could not have escaped
the label anyway when she stepped into
the national limelight as an atheist
most Americans could not help but see
her as a communist as well and therefore
a national threat similarly atheism and
immorality were linked Cold War
Americans believe that be a morte to be
a moral person you had to be religious
probably Christian therefore Americans
associated O'Hair with what they saw as
the growing immoral
of post-war America and her private life
confirmed that Association in the minds
of many this person's denial of God has
opened the door to a selfish vulgar and
often immoral lifestyle wrote one
observer words like liar cheater
hypocrite publicity seeker only
scratched the surface in describing this
individual's depth of personal
corruption
for many Americans O'Hare was proof that
the arch enemy was real and in their
midst as I'll show in a moment Madeleine
McNair Madalyn Murray O'Hair was no
angel she violated some of the nation's
most sacred codes of behavior but she
didn't have to put her transgressions on
display for the nation to see others
shared her beliefs and engaged in the
same socially unacceptable behavior but
they chose to do so quietly out of the
limelight O'Hare seized the moment
claimed full responsibility and
challenged the believing public to
contend with her I'm more than an
atheist I'm in fact the atheist Madalyn
Murray O'Hair in 1965 Playboy magazine
asked Madeleine her for a crusade to
separate church and state was her raison
d'etre she replied that it was only one
expression of her raison d'etre she was
an atheist but she was also an anarchist
a feminist an integrationist
internationalist all the other ists that
people seem to find so horrible today I
embraced them all the public response to
O'Hare may best be described as a
firestorm and as even one of her critics
was forced to admit he had never seen
anyone with such a breathtaking
willingness to endure public hatred but
why did she do this why did she so
willingly assume such a persona as one
critic puzzled she thoroughly
personified the Christian stereotype of
an atheist rude and pertinent
blasphemous a destroyer not only of
beliefs but also of esteemed values she
popped off like a chain of fireworks in
a sanctuary merrily detonate
everything we hold dear it was
impossible not to admire her nerve while
at the same time wandering at her
apparent in compulsion to be loathed was
she simply committed to changing the
world to making it by her way of
thinking a better more humane place not
entirely there were some personal
reasons for her behavior as well and
that takes us back really to her early
life and I would say that one thing that
really helped me through this is I was
the first other than a few newspaper if
you will actually have access to her
Diaries which really did open up a whole
new area of this exploration Madeleine
was born Madeleine Evelyn Mays on April
13th 1919 in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
Natalie recalled I don't believe there
could have been a happier a more secure
childhood than mine
she described her mother is beautiful
her father is a knight in shining armor
in her life as growing up amidst
affluence typically the account was
exaggerated but Madeleine did live a
comfortable life as a child at least
until the Great Depression when the
stock market crash destroyed her
father's business and then for the next
several years the family moved from
place to place while John Mays sought
work and money to support his wife and
children
Madeleine often referred to those years
in their influence on her later life if
once prosperous and carefree that was no
longer the case moreover by her telling
the hardship she suffered bored the
seeds of her later rejection of God
her father was presbytery and her mother
was Lutheran her parents baptized
nate'll in the Presbyterian Church at
the age of four and she attended church
on an Sunday school somewhat irregularly
then at the age of 12 or 13 as Madeleine
tells it while in the sixth grade and
living in Akron Ohio
Madeleine read the Bible she read it
cover to cover in one weekend she later
reported and quote realized it was a
perfectly bizarre book she was
completely appalled totally turned off
and filled with repugnance by what she
discovered
I came away stunned with the hatred the
brutality the sadomasochism the cruelty
the killing the ugliness at about the
same time while attending church she
began to take note of the minister's
accusing his flock of being full of sin
though he never explained why instead
they passed a collection plate and I got
in my mind that this had to do with the
purification of the soul that we were
being invited to by expiation for our
sins so I gave it all up it was too
nonsensical the maze were not
enthusiastic churchgoers as I mentioned
earlier nevertheless when Madeline
explained her conclusions concerning the
Bible to her parents and read them the
offending passages her mother simply
drew herself up and responded that's not
my Bible nataline was not to be
dissuaded however I never accepted the
Bible after that day I refused to go to
Sunday school anymore and I refused to
go to church the Mays family may have
been poor as a result of the depression
but in 1936 Madeline was able to spend
one year at the University of Toledo in
1938-39 she enrolled at the University
of Pittsburgh when the family returned
to that city but she did not graduate
instead on October 9th 1941 at age 22
she eloped with John Henry Roth's a
steelworker a local guy who Madeline had
met in high school two months later the
Roth's marriage was disrupted by
American involvement in world war ii
both enlisted but received separate
assignments he became a Marine and was
sent to the Pacific she enlisted in the
woman's auxilary Army Corps and was
commissioned as a second lieutenant she
served on the cryptographic staff in the
supreme Allied headquarters in North
Africa France and Italy while stationed
in Italy
lieutenant Madeline Roth's met and
conceived the child with William Murray
jr. an officer in the u.s. 8th Army
Corps according to their sons William
when Madeline returned her son William
when Madeline returned home from the war
her parents were living in a
with no electricity or running water her
father had spent on booze all the money
she had sent for savings the family was
destitute she was pregnant when broths
returned he offered the stay with his
wife and raised the child as his own
but O'Hare declined and proceeded to sue
for divorce
according to Madeline Marie refute Marie
the father of the child refused to leave
his wife because he was a Catholic and
opposed to divorce but he actually
denied he was the father
forcing Madeleine to establish his
paternity in court in order to receive
child support although William Marie's
refusal to divorce his wife could not be
ascribed then so Lolita is being a
Catholic his son concluded that it
provoked into his mother's antagonism
toward Roman Catholicism which was
always her prime enemy and God the
latter symbolized by one of the most
dramatic episodes in Madeline's life one
night in early 1946 during a violent
electrical storm
Madeleine still pregnant and in despair
announced that she was going out in the
storm to challenge God to strike her and
her unborn child dead with lightning
bolts she stood in the rain waving her
fists cursing God and when nothing
happened
shirt went back into the house and said
you see if God exists he would surely
have taken up my challenge I've proved
irrefutably that God does not exist
Madeleine attempted to rebuild her life
she graduated from Ashland College in
1948 and from South Texas School of Law
in 1952 in 1952 John Mays sister-in-law
invited him to join her family's
business in Baltimore Maryland
they bought a small brick row house at
1526 Winfred Road in a quiet
middle-class neighborhood and Madeleine
began her diary in which she voiced some
guarded optimism for the future
On January fifth 1953 as her first entry
she wrote the year has the look in the
feel of a good one well paced
eventful
prosperous she nevertheless listed
several issues that gave her pause and
even presented a dismal foundation on
which to build so she wrote to begin
with she found that the Maryland Bar
Examiners did not recognize her law
degree because South Texas law school
had not yet been accredited so she
couldn't take the bar exam second the
family continued to be in financial
difficulties
Madeline reported that her former
employer had written a condemning note
to the pub to the de public Department
of Public Welfare for whom she wanted to
work and that she had been forced to
take a job at the Glenelg Martin company
instead she hated the job and as months
passed even this level of Madeline's
optimism slowly waned in her frustration
groove the family's financial situation
improved only slightly and she felt
trapped by her job and frustrated by her
life she observed in her diary I don't
like these row houses nests of bees
identical homes with identical people
and identical lives yet truly I longed
to be part of society I would like to
have a routine humdrum existence or so
I've thought a set of contradictions if
there ever was one
Madeline had moments of renewed optimism
and satisfaction but generally the
remaining years of the decade as
reflected in her diary were marred by
even greater despair and anger both with
herself and the world around her she
condemned her own laziness and mistakes
but she also condemned the society in
which she lived for the situation in
which she found herself at that point I
may 16th 1953 she confided to her diary
there's nothing for me ahead but a petty
existence eked out from day to day I'm
frustrated and bitter and full of hate
Madeline also commented on world and
national events again in an increasingly
critical manner she grew highly critical
of Joseph McCarthy Richard Nixon in the
anti-communist movement
she joined Americans for democratic
action than the socialist Labour Party
and then the Socialist Workers Party
Madeleine became an early proponent of
famine
an opponent of French and American
involvement in Vietnam she opposed the
Korean War the testing of nuclear
weapons in the atmosphere and
suppression of the rights of Algeria uns
and black South Africans and a proponent
of improving the lot of migrant workers
but Madeleine couldn't live by politics
alone on July 3rd 1953 she wrote in her
diary I need to unlock again my emotions
I need to love
I've been pent up and hard and cynical
too long I need to be a woman soon
thereafter Madeleine began seeing
Michael Fiorello from New York City whom
she met at work she confided to her
diary that she felt like a high school
girl again he folded me into his arms
and naturally and completely kissed me
like I have wanted to be kissed for 20
years I was so absolutely pleased and
surprised
I almost got kittenish interesting image
from Madeleine oh here on November 16th
1954 Madeleine gave birth to her second
out of wedlock child whom she married
John Garth Murray after the father of
her first son Fiorello challenged his
paternity of John Garth but lost again I
would remind you this is the 1950s
Madeleine also ruminated about her
social situation I say I have bad luck
but don't we make our luck isn't it a
combination of poor judgment and
indiscretion then there's a pause in a
very key transition I don't really
believe that why do I write it I see
social mores that are wrong stupid in a
moral the people who live by the mores
see me as a flagrant violator an
extremist something foreign to them and
dangerous by the early months of 1955
Madeleine hid absolute bottom but she
refused to be counted out as there was
no place to go but up she attacked the
moral code inculcated in school church
and other institutions she explained
that she ignored the code completely and
lived by raw rules
disgust revolt and injured everyone is
playing a horrible game of lip service
versus the darkest and most cruel
conduct in dead earnest Ness its macabre
an hysterically funny
these dart games are dangerous and men
die for false ideals and distorted
truths and will for ever and ever amen
the question she continued was how to
resolve yourself to this insane
situation the answer she suggested to
reject it indeed to topple it
consequently I will be ostracized
she wrote by my own volition from
society henceforth and since I've
decided I'm rather happy about it
although she would waver in her
commitment from time to time Madeleine
was committed to a life of confrontation
with American society what she needed
was a cause Madelyn might have committed
herself to any number of causes her
feminism nuclear disarmament social
reform political activism atheism was
neither hiromi nor even really at this
point her primary concern as the decade
drew to a close
Madeleine contemplated how she would
sort of translate this into an action
against the world and she began to think
about first of all leaving the country
she thought about renouncing her
citizenship and even the possibility of
defecting to the Soviet Union but she
abandoned that idea and resolved the
focus or energy on reforming the United
States that idea and she then decided
she would enroll at Howard University a
traditionally black institution seeking
a master's degree in psychiatric work
but she was expelled after quarreling
with her advisor Madeleine found the job
in the Social Security Administration
but was fired and during the spring in
summer of 1959 for about three months
she moved to a new apartment with a man
called Ricardo she left her sons in the
care of her parents admitted that her
family wasn't happy with their decision
she hoped all would be reconciled in
time but the relationship fail
and she moved back home again this is
when she took on the Baltimore Public
Schools when they moved the Baltimore
Madeleine enrolled William in part
school a private school and then which
then moved to West Baltimore and William
had to commute to the school after a
semester of an exhausting long commute
and a struggle to meet the tuition bills
she decided to switch him to the local
public school William later recalled
that as they passed through the halls of
Woodbourne
junior high his mother was perturbed to
see the student standing and pledging
allegiance to the flag and angry when
she observed them bowing their head and
reciting the Lord's Prayer upon entering
the counselor's office
Madeleine confronted the men who greeted
her asking why the students were praying
it's on America it's unconstitutional
she proclaimed and let him know that she
did not want her son to be taught any
prayers the man was clearly flustered by
Madeline's charge and at first responded
by noting that nobody else had ever
complained and that even those who were
not very religious thought prayer
recitations at a nice tone for the day
after he regained his composure he added
there were prayers in the school of the
city before there was a United States of
America if our forefathers had wanted us
to stop this practice they would have
told us that when they formed this
government his response infuriated
Madeleine he probably should have
stopped there she informed the counselor
that people like him had to be stopped
whereupon he replied then why don't you
sue us
he could not have anticipated what he
had suggested that the viewer on October
27th 1960 the face of William Murray
graced page 1 of the Baltimore Morning
Sun beneath the headline boy 14 box at
Bible reading the three column article
reported the facts of the case the
Murray's position and that this was the
first reported challenge to the
Baltimore school board's rule on prayer
since its adoption in 1905 telephone
calls began immediately for some local
reporters the national reporters all
seeking interviews on November 2nd 1960
Maryland Attorney General C Ferdinand
Seibert ruled that objections to
exercise exercises were not a valid
reason for non-compliance with the
public school law and that anyone who
have scented himself from school to
avoid them could be prosecuted for
truancy Seibert recommended that pupils
who objected to bible reading or school
prayer be allowed to remain silent upon
the written request of their parents or
be excused from the exercise he
acknowledged that such nonconformity
would cause individual embarrassment but
that was the price to be paid for
nonconformity now there was a little bit
for everybody in this ruling the morning
religious exercises remain but the
Murrays won the right to absent william
from it madeleine however viewed the
decision is almost total victory for the
school board and would not compromise
she pressed on the Murrays attorney
filed a petition for a writ of mandamus
on December 8th 1960 in the Superior
Court of Baltimore the case initially
called William J Murray the third versus
Baltimore School Board became Murray V
curl it curl it being the school board
president on April 27th 1961 judge
Gilbert Pendergast dismissed the Murrays
petition and the Murrays appealed the
decision to the Maryland Court of
Appeals and that Court ruled against the
Murrays as well and finally the Murrays
appealed the court of the united the
case to the United States Supreme Court
or it was joined with Shemp the case
I mentioned earlier which came out at
Pennsylvania where the state court
actually ruled that the state law was
unconstitutional so it was an
interesting joining of cases on June
17th 1963 the US Supreme Court returned
the murray and Shemp cases the court
declared unconstitutional the Maryland
and Pennsylvania laws requiring Bible
reading and prayer recitation in the
public schools because they violated the
Establishment Clause of the First
Amendment the majority opinion
maintained that the Establishment Clause
is violated by any government
sponsorship of religion in the public
schools regardless of whether a showing
of coercion exists this was a reference
to the delighting yeah and William have
the opportunity to leave the room as
justice Tom Clark put it for a law to be
valid there must be a secular
legislative purpose in a primary effect
that neither advances nor inhibits
religion and the Maryland and
Pennsylvania laws fail that test
Madeleine Marie felt vindicated by the
decision and she best in the sunlight of
public and media attention she vowed to
go beyond removing prayer and Bible
reading from the nation's public schools
but has it been the case throughout her
adult life she was not without her
personal second thoughts she continually
struggled to understand herself in her
seemingly uncontrollable need to
challenge and change some of the most
dearly held beliefs in the world around
her several years after the cases were
decided she described one such
contemplated contemplative moment one
evening in Baltimore she as she sat
alone in her basement library trying to
decide whether to press ahead with the
lawsuit Madden reflected on her sense of
separateness when we first moved into
those row houses in Baltimore she wrote
I think I had picked out one for
purchase deliberately in the hopes that
I could be like everyone else I had
wanted so desperately to fit in but I
could not engage in conversation about
which bleach was the whitest for the
wash I never gave a damn about
chlorophyll and toothpaste
the idiotic idea of back fence visiting
left me completely cold she acknowledged
that none of her work had ever fully
occupied her mind and thinking processes
and that out of frustration she would
too often paced the basement library
floor like a lioness caged
the rapp of loneliness of aloneness
always around me I just wanted one
person somewhere some time to understand
me and argued that the singular
importance of Marie V curl it was the
involvement of Madeleine Marie who sees
the opportunity to attain national
notoriety as the leader of the American
atheist movement when the newspapers
reported on the Marie Shemp decision
Madeleine William and John Garth were
pictured standing on the steps of the US
Supreme Court building the chef's were
nowhere to be found soon every newspaper
magazine and radio and television
commentator in the land referred to her
as the woman who brought the case that
removed prayer and Bible reading from
the schools and Madeleine resented any
attempt to limit her responsibility in
those cases she laid claim to being the
primary figure in the 1963 Supreme Court
decision by arguing that Edward Shemp in
his failure to seize the moment and lead
the movement for separation of church
and state forfeited that role 40 years
after she initiated the case four years
after her mysterious disappearance the
Washington Post made the point that the
Murrays were neither the only plaintiffs
involved in the 63 Supreme Court ruling
but they weren't even essential nataline
however it added was the litigant with
the loudest mouth in a major a celebrity
one of the earliest major published
expose Zahn Madeline Murray appeared in
Life magazine in 1964 life used as it's
titled the most hated woman in America
making it household currency author Jane
Howard described Madeleine as America's
most outspoken and militant atheist her
cause was the total and utter separation
of church and state in a land where most
people believe in God
and those who don't keep quiet Howard
wrote such a cause is as good a way to
win public favor is bringing back polio
Marie she added which outlawed official
prayer ceremonies in public schools and
made the name of Marie anathema to
millions of Americans
Madeleine agreed with Howard's
assessment and made no to the death
threats she had received Madeleine said
that she loved life that that she simply
had to fight which she knew in her guts
was wrong she quipped I think sooner or
later
sunlight some nuts going to get a
message from Jesus Christ and I'm going
to have had it but as long as I'm still
around I'm going to keep on being a
squeaking wheel now I don't have time to
go into her life after Marie in any
great detail but let me just comment out
it briefly because I think it's
important Madeleine Marie issued to her
challenge to the Baltimore public
schools during the Cold War this helps
explain the public reaction to her
protest against prayer in the public
schools in the outrage at her success
indeed although it made her the most
hated woman in America it also made her
one of the best-known and it gave her a
cause that would serve her well during
the quite different reform-minded
countercultural
even iconoclastic late 1960s and 1970s
it was during those years that Madalyn
Murray O'Hair as head of American
Atheists in Society for the separation
of church and state reached her peak of
popularity and influence she and her
organizations challenged the words under
God and the Pledge of Allegiance
In God We Trust on American currency the
tax-exempt status of religious
organizations the use of chaplains in
the military and open sessions of
government the Pope's performance of
Mass on the Washington Mall USS tour
nots reading the Bible in space and much
more the list goes on she lost most of
her cases
but as she readily admitted she never
expected to win at least in the short
run what she saw was to make cases for
what she saw as violations of
institutions for the separation of
church and state and the rights of
atheists as well as what she saw as the
destructive oppressive power of religion
in America in the most visible men to
educate Americans really on these
matters for the future she believed that
although a fervent minority believed in
and defended this unofficial de facto
establishment of religion most did not
or didn't care not seeing the danger of
it and therefore could be persuaded to
oppose it and for a time during the
1960s and 70s O'Hara was one of the most
visible reformers in America she was on
every major TV and radio talk show her
face was on the cover of every leading
magazine her actions were covered
regularly in the press the FBI had a
file on her when I wrote that I realized
that they had a file on everybody so
that wasn't any great accomplishment
death war death threats against her were
a common occurrence and she often had to
be hustled away under guard when her
public remarks incited crowds to
menacing levels but then the times
changed again the Cold War reheated
during the Reagan years complete with
renewed ideological Crusades against the
evil empire and turning a cold shoulder
to liberals reformers and those standing
outside the new ideological mainstream
the more conservative mood of the nation
the fact that much of what people found
so shocking and appealing about O'Hair
and her cause during the previous
decades became old hat and the errors
made on her own part all precipitated
O'Hare's gradual decline O'Hair roared
in opposition to the Reagan decade but
she was tilting with the windmills
especially when those to whom she once
appealed tired of the battle for liberal
reform and might well have been heard to
respond
Madeleine we've heard it before as
O'Hair too lived into her mid-60s and
once again faced issues she thought long
ago resolved she increasingly despaired
it spoke of ill health and being
busted she rallied at times in
challenging the new Christian right and
allied forces must had to drag the
nation back into the Dark Ages as she
saw it but then her son William Murray
and whose names she brought the case
defected was born again and became her
enemy the press had a field day with the
turn of events and its coverage of
American atheist activities was limited
to periodic confrontations between the
two groups portrayed much like the
carnival come to town
complete with sideshows and other
attractions at which to marvel or laugh
but certainly not to take seriously as
O'Hare prepared to retire her American
atheist faced its most serious challenge
since its inception when O'Hare rose to
prominence attracted people she
attracted people to her and expanded her
operation she also became increasingly
dictatorial she had no patience with
those of lesser skills in energy or who
challenged or even questioned her and as
a result she alienated many of those who
might have served her organization well
this was not a significant problem as
long as she had the limelight it became
a problem as she lost that prominence
and members of her own organization
began to blame her for the decline of
the movement and sought to remove her
from power others simply sensed no doubt
her growing weakness and moved in for
the kill for their own reasons trusting
no one beyond her immediate circle
O'Hare insisted on passing the baton to
her son John Garth Murray his leadership
and interpersonal skills were
questionable and the method by which he
was thrust into power outraged many
within the national organization
combined with its mounting financial
problems on the on the eve of Madeleine
John and Robin Marie's disappearance in
1995 American Atheists seemed on the
verge of being torn apart if not
collapsing all together but Madalyn
Murray O'Hair life ended on a much more
bizarre note on August 28th 1995
Madeleine John and Robin Murray Robin
was Madeleine's grin
daughter who is actually Williams
daughter estranged disappeared
speculation arose that Madeline had died
in net John and Robin and secret of her
body away for cremation and burial out
of the public eye as Madeline had
requested some believe that the trio had
fled the country due to their financial
problems absconded with whatever
organization money's remained this
interpretation stuck by the way I just
got off the net there's a production
opening in New York at the wash and fold
theater project I'm from New York that's
a new one on me and it's called the last
days of Madalyn Murray O'Hair in exile
and what it has is Madalyn Murray O'Hair
absconded with the money living on a
South Sea Island and going through sort
of rethinking her whole life so this
this interpretation appealed to a lot of
people and of course a few thought they
had been murdered bombed some by some
irate Kreisler as she put it whom Madame
predicted all along would kill her
indeed the trio had been murdered but
not by a christ group instead they were
killed by an ex-con in former employee
whom Madeleine once charged with theft
of organization funds David waters
entered a plea of guilty in that case in
exchange for probation and was ordered
to make restitution he also vowed
revenge a vow he kept waters and two
accomplices abducted the trio forced
them to withdraw over five hundred
thousand dollars from the organization's
bank accounts killed them dismembered
their bodies and buried them in shallow
graves outside San Antonio Texas in
January 2001 waters once again in a plea
bargain led authorities to those graves
where the remains were recovered William
Murray claimed and buried them without
prayer in an undisclosed location in the
hills near Austin well let me conclude
by just talking a little bit about
Madeline's legacy she's gone but
certainly not forgotten or at least her
legacy continues to challenge us to this
day many Americans still refusing to
accept the Supreme Court's ruling and
Murray continue to seek
creative and constitutionally acceptable
ways around that decision in other
challenges that Madeline brought but
failed to win continue to be brought up
the most recent being the case brought
by Michael Newdow on behalf of his
eight-year-old daughter to the ninth US
Circuit Court of Appeals in San
Francisco which resulted in a ruling
that the words under God were
unconstitutional when uttered by
teachers leading school children in
their morning exercises in the midst of
dying telecoms charges of corruption
lodged against major corporations an
exploding deficit a Middle East in
flames the decision still set off such
an uproar that the judge in the case
alfred goodwin felt obliged to block his
own ruling until a higher court had a
chance to hear the case and I really
think Madeline would have been much
amused if she'd been around at that
point thank you
be happy to take some questions or do
these try to answer them ballpark how
many legal cases did she bring and did
she ever represent herself or did she
always even with her law background or
did she always get legal counsel
she brought hundreds of cases and was
responsible for hundreds more because
her organization also had stake state
and local chapters and she would work
with them to bring cases at one point is
funny in the early part of her career
she was convinced that the Supreme Court
was the only way to go because they were
the only ones with courage came out of
the Murray decision then later on she
kind of decided well that's not where we
want to go cuz she thought the tone of
the court was changing so she changed
her focus to start all their cases at
the local level saying we can change
things here and she was very dramatic
about going into she lived in Austin
Texas so she would go into the Austin
City Council Chambers and demand that
they not pray before you know the
session that this was her delayed
feeling if grassroots kind of behavior
was the way to go so she did bring all
of these cases now she never took the
bar exam and so she could never practice
law she could never sign or represent
herself and in that sense she always had
attorneys who work for her to do it but
by all measures all references sometimes
angrily
by her attorneys she insisted on writing
many of the briefs herself she just she
would write them and have them sign it
if they tried to change anything she
just sort of tear it out of their hands
and say you're done and that was the end
of it so she did write many of them or
so and they are really written very I I
would recommend many of the statements
the briefs that were entered in the
Murray case I think the best
representation of atheism in America
that you're going to get they're really
very good
before I came tonight I was talking with
somebody about your book and they said
Madalyn Murray O'Hair gave atheists a
bad name did she catch much heat from
within the movement to tone it down and
try to become more you know yeah mom and
pop atheism right that's a good question
a way to get kind of relates back to
Maura's question earlier in when she
talked about her being is one of many
liberals of the time her behavior was
such that other liberals if we can call
her a liberal and almost you know so
many people in her movement rejected her
because she was just so studiedly crude
and vulgar that people just wouldn't
have anything to do with her
at first they were okay through much of
the 60s because that was kind of a crazy
time anyway and everyone was acting bad
you know it was easy in a sense for
Madeleine she had lots of cover for her
behavior
as you go into the late 70s into the 80s
in a more civil time if you want did you
take that as a positive or negative view
of the time people really began to just
reject her and whenever she was rejected
she tended to be even more outrageous in
her behavior one typical scene and it
comes you know she had a great way of
mimicking so people wouldn't miss the
point
she went into a bingo game in a church
and did the Christ thing from the New
Testament went in and tipped over the
tables and started screaming at the top
of her lungs in order to make the point
this was sort of typical and they did
distant that many people did distance
herself from themselves from her
many times the Americans who are
perceived in their own country are
admired and revered abroad for example
Woody Allen in France Marilyn Monroe
Jerry Lewis Roman Polanski well he was a
European though how do you have any
information about how she was accepted
abroad chests diced here an outsider but
was she respected elsewhere she actually
started the International atheist
Association she started hurt herself and
she was she was fairly well regarded
abroad she tended to behave a little
better when she went abroad and I think
that helped to and also people were less
obsessed with atheists in the movement
abroad so she could go as she did to
Sweden Denmark India France many places
and meet with atheists and no one really
cared you know what didn't you didn't
bring about the reaction that it did in
the United States so she didn't have
that kind of visibility but she seems to
have been fairly highly regarded enough
to be elected the president of that
group for several years so she did
pretty well abroad
I have a question to go back to the
Diaries I'm always interested in
documentation of scholarship and so on
how did you gain access to the Diaries
and did you have access to documents
that the American Atheists keep or or
even documents of our enemies and so
forth let me answer the first question
about the Diaries the diaries were when
they were found were actually sold at an
auction to help pay off the
organization's debts they were purchased
by an attorney from Austin and it took
me about a year to persuade him for
reasons which I'm still not quite sure
to let me use to read the diaries and
I'm very grateful I did not intend to
include much of Madeline's personal life
in this book I really wanted to look at
a theism in Cold War America as an issue
with Madeline as a representation of
that issue most of the stuff that had
been written about Madeline was pretty
antagonistic and what I found from my
research most of it was wrong and that's
why I had to in a sense retreat and I
was also constantly challenged by this
idea of why did she do it and it really
took the Diaries to help me figure that
out also purchased as part of the
diaries were many boxes of personal
documents from her life which was
another one birth certificates that's
another story
read the chapter in the book birth
certificates because she not she would
have one birth certificate for her son
William which was probably the original
one then she wasn't had a second one
done with different names and she did
the same thing when her second son was
born and she was constantly playing if
you will these kinds of games but the
documentation is really there there's
quite a bit now as far as the American
Atheists are concerned I
was not very successful they were very
protective of her I think I would have
had better luck if she hadn't
disappeared when I was writing the book
and then they were under such siege
thinking that she'd absconded with the
money that they sort of drew up the
drawbridge and decided they weren't
gonna let anyone near that documentation
however having said that I it worked out
okay because really there isn't much
personal material and American Atheists
there's a lot of literature it's a
wonderful collection on atheism Madeline
collected it but there wasn't a lot of
personal papers
one thing about Madeline Madeline wrote
everything down and got it published
chin newsletters she had magazines
she had a radio show and then published
the transcripts in the radio shows so
there wasn't much that Madeline thought
or said it didn't make it into print so
yes if I can follow on that question was
Madeline spiritual did she believe in
spirituality and in examining her
Diaries do you perceive it all over time
any kind of spiritual or even emotional
growth going on Oh interesting ending to
that question I didn't detect very much
of anything in terms of a spiritual
understanding there's just nothing there
the deal with she was a committed as she
believed rationalist who just didn't
believe in any kind of spiritual focus
or force in the world I didn't see very
much there at all and I think if
anything rather than looking at it in
terms of spiritual growth I think of
anything whatever spiritual feeling she
might have had were lost over time she
died or in her last few she was a very
very bitter angry woman at the end
we mentioned in Europe that she could
become well-behaved I wonder was there
anything endearing or soft about this
woman or was it a show
I mean understanding a little bit about
the atheist leaders now and the
organization's it's a plethora of people
being shunned and splitting off and so
it seems more normal right to me so I
just wondering is that is this harshness
just part of a show or I think to a
large extent it was it was who was her
performance so that she would be noticed
but she was a pretty outspoken woman and
even those who liked her said that in
private she was pretty tough to be
around
she didn't tolerate fools well at all
and if you said something she didn't
agree with she let you know there was no
question on the other hand they say she
had a fabulous sense of humor and you
know could be fun to be around but those
people were pretty few and far between I
think the frustration came out you know
with her over the years now you
mentioned Europe I think one of the
reasons again I want to emphasize that I
believe that she was better behaved in
Europe is because she didn't have the
spotlight to misbehave they didn't care
that she was there so there's another
atheist group it just wasn't a big issue
in Europe one of the things that kind of
ignited her in the United States was
that she wherever she went the spotlight
was on her and she would seize it by
behaving the way she did I suppose she
could have engaged in some outrageous
behavior abroad but she just didn't it
wasn't there
in your reading of her Diaries and in
your discussion of that early period of
her life and her own comment about I
believe it was in what in a later period
of her life where she wondered to
herself why she always wanted to be
angry and and against something it
sounded as though you might be implying
that she was or portraying her as a
rebel with the cause by nature that that
was her sort of fundamental personality
bent and further that that perhaps more
than anything more than particular
rational beliefs might be what was
driving her and I just wonder if you
would comment further on that if that is
what you're implying in the book and if
she ever herself seemed to if that is
the case
did she ever herself seem to come to
some kind of an understanding about what
was making her tick in terms of why she
needed to be always against something to
thrive yeah clearly there was a
rebellious nature there and she knew it
I think to a certain extent anyone in
that situation you must have had moments
of loneliness when she wished she wasn't
the way that she was because she led I
mean there's a pretty desperate life oh
I didn't go into it but the two or three
years after the Murray case she had had
guards her house was stoned windows
broken tires slash her sons were beat up
William was thrown before a bus I mean
it was pretty tough going and I'm sure
that she had moments when she wished
things were different but I think she
she was either worked in to put herself
into a situation where she had nothing
else that she could do but fight back
and one could put a gendered
interpretation of what's going on but I
really do see this as a woman in the
early 50s
very bright very well educated made some
mistake
and never got over it and decided rather
than apologizing for it she was gonna
pull the system down around her I really
think that was a lot of the motivation
okay well thank you very much I
appreciate it
[Music]
Brian LeBeau is author of the Atheist
Madalyn Murray O'Hair it's published by
New York University Press on the web at
NYU press dot org next week on public
lives a new biography of Andrew Jackson
from